when eric beach was a student at
stanford he presented his phd thesis
which addressed physically based
lighting and shading one of his
inventions was a multiple important
sampling which made physically based
rendering feasible multiple important
sampling can most easily be defined as
matching virtual light to a virtual
material this research lets digital
artists focus on cinematography rather
than rendering the the unified the
unified theory and formalization of
monte carlo path tracing is a universal
reference the academy presents eric
veach with a scientific and engineering
award please join us to accept this
award
well this is big news in my family since
as my wife luanne pointed out this means
she can't make jokes about my thesis
anymore
in fact she was so excited that she ran
down to the basement to get a copy and
put it on our coffee table
so so then i was explaining to my son
malcolm who was 11 a few days later that
i was getting this award because you
know some people have read my thesis and
we're using it to make movies
so he points over at my thesis which is
about two inches thick and says
they read that
but seriously i'm very grateful uh to
the people who have read my thesis and
found something worthwhile there
because it takes a whole lot of work to
go from a few ideas to making movies
and without those people and their hard
work i wouldn't be here so i really
appreciate
everyone for that and
i'd also like to thank my advisor leo
gibas for his support and my wife luanne
for all of her support
thank you